I recently have had some very concerning numbers on my complete metabolic panel, so it's
a blood test, a complete metabolic panel, Alconphosphatase is 287, I think, lab ranges of
Alconphosphatase. It turns out what lab, but most lab ranges, the high is like 140, but really
the functional range for Alconphosphatase high range is more like, you know, 125, some people would
even say, you know, about the high range should be like 100. So I would, you know, when you have
what happens, what would that be a sign up? What would elevated Alconphosphatase be a sign up?
Well, you have to look at it in the bigger picture with other things. So here you gave me a couple
other signs. Your AST and your ALT are both elevated. So Alconphosphatase is released by multiple
tissues. AST and ALT is really only from your liver. So when Alconphosphatase is elevated along with
AST and ALT, it gives you a clue that it could be your liver. So what could cause Alconphosphatase,
AST and ALT to elevate from the liver? Most common thing would be the use of medications. So drugs
have to detoxify through the phase one phase two cytochrome P450 and AT pathways in the liver
and can overwhelm the liver and cause inflammation of the liver and cause elevation of Alconphosphatase
T and ALT. That's the most common thing. Other things can be other issues with one's liver. So someone,
not anybody on this call, but somebody could have alcoholic liver syndrome because they're drinking
alcohol. Their liver is toxic due to other things. So liver failure, liver markers can be elevated
as well. But there's other things that can raise Alconphosphatase. So if Alconphosphatase was
elevated, AST was normal and ALT was normal, then you would be thinking of issues with the bone,
especially given a history of cancer, what when a person has metastasis to bone and bone
destruction, bone can release Alconphosphatase. So a person could have elevated Alconphosphatase
because of bone destruction, because of metastasis to bone, but it would spare the liver markers.
So the AST and the ALT would be within normal range. But so the other thing that could
raise Alconphosphatase and it would raise AST and ALT is if there's bile destruction or bile
obstruction. So your liver sends the toxins that are funneled through the liver and produced
as an end product of detoxification in the blood, sends it, what's those toxins into the bile,
and then the bile goes through the bile duct down into the duodenum. It combines with the
pancreas in the common bile duct, goes through your gallbladder and then goes into the first part of
the small intestine called the duodenum. If there's a blockage anywhere along that way,
it blockage in the gallbladder, a blockage in the common bile duct, a blockage in the bile duct
in the liver that would also elevate Alconphosphatase AST and ALT. So those are the things that you'd want
to figure out. Now, if a person is like, okay, these were within normal range and they were
having creepyed up since I started chemo, okay, then you'd be like, okay, well, then that could
be the cause of it. Typically, if there's bile obstruction, you may also have elevated bile
rupture. So you'd want to look at other markers as well. So any one marker can mean lots of different
things and what they, how you help to serve that is looking at other things as well. So I want to
look at the rest of your blood work as well. Like I said, Alconphosphatase is going to be typically
elevated with bony destruction, but a person could have bony destruction and some issues with the liver
at the same time. Then you'd want to also look at calcium levels. So if there's bony destruction,
that's fairly aggressive, then you're also going to have elevated calcium levels. So you've got to look
at the big picture as much as possible and then you don't just look at blood, you look at the person's
symptoms, subjective things, and you also look at other tests that are done. So if we knew the total
cause of this, then we could answer this next part of the question, is there anything I could do
to diet wise to improve these numbers? Well, number one, doing coffee enemies could be your best friend
because we know that there's liver involvement with AST and ALT. We just don't know why. If it is
some bile duct obstruction, coffee enemies are going to help with that. Doing casteril packs over the
liver could also be a good thing. That's why we recommend those things because they're good for
multiple different causes of issues. So if it's bile duct obstruction, if it's issues with inflammation
and the liver, if it's issues with detoxification and the liver, because it's becoming overwhelmed,
because I'm trying to detox people therapy or something, coffee enemies and casteril packs over the
liver are going to do nothing but help that flow. So foods that can help these things again, it depends.
So we're helping support liver pathways as best we can. Artichoke is a great thing for liver pathways,
beetroot is great thing for liver pathways. So those are some things that I just thought I would stop
my hand there. So answer the question. Best want to look at the whole big picture
to help deserve as best as possible, you know, why these numbers are elevated.